it's the semi-finals of my best
restaurant competition Britain's High
streets are packed full of wonderful
restaurants but with so much competition
out there how do you spot the difference
between a good restaurant and a great
one tonight we'll find
out earlier this year I asked you to
nominate your favorite restaurants and
you bombarded me with thousands of
nominations my team and I chose the best
restaurants and put them through their
Paces now the winners of eight Heats are
going to battle out for a place in the
final it's going to be a tough
competition with four brilliant
restaurants fighting for a place in the
final my best Spanish feno my best
Chinese youu from Blackburn my best
Italian cmir from Bristol and my best
high restaurant Nam Jim from St Andrews
only one of these four amazing
restaurants will go through to the final
and there's a surprise in store I'm
going to kick two of them out right now
it's sudden death
elimination to be with a Chance of
becoming my best best restaurant all my
semi-finalists will need to be faultless
you've got to take criticism
seriously I want to know if they've
corrected the problems I identified
earlier in the competition it needed
more
seasoning to help me find out I've sent
back in my team of secret
diners two of these restaurants will be
leaving the competition
immediately first to risk the chop is my
best Italian Casmir from Bristol
Brothers John Ray and Peter are young
and ambitious and produce delicious food
but earlier in the competition I
discovered that some of the avangard
dishes were confusing diners is the fish
meant to be cooked like this it's a bit
of a strange consistency it is I sent in
a new secret diner food expert Rob
Allison to find out if the boys are
reigned in their wild
experimentation these guys definitely
understand
flavors ABS totally understand it a star
I've never thought of it working with
all I've never even imagined it before
it work deliciously every time these
boys create a dish there's huge Jeopardy
olives with star andise doesn't sound
like a perfect combination but yet again
they've pulled it off next roast lamb
SED with kidneys and pine nuts the lamb
is delicious the best end in the kidney
um it will work so Pine but what about
the addition of vacuum packed cucumber
to the day
I'm not too
sure yeah
weird it's
weird damn just when you think you're
taking off it it crash lands they seem
so head up with being Cutting Edge on
the edge of all the innovations that go
on in food that they've actually
forgotten but what they're actually
serving is to be eaten and it's to be
enjoyed and it's not to be dissected in
of a biological
experiment much of the food at Casmir is
magical but some of the dishes are still
misfiring it sounds really negative and
it sounds like yeah we we could be
possibly going home there's that's the
way it
looks next to face the video evidence is
Chinese winner you andu from Blackburn
in
Lancashire father Charlie and his son
headchef Victor were Overjoyed to win
their heat you and you oh
but I had concerns they were heavily
overstaffed we having a beauty pageant
in here look all these waitresses in
here Blackburn's Next Top Model it's an
issue that needs to be addressed quite a
lot of stuff it's not really that busy
is it I think the problem is when you
get a lot of stuff and the restaurant's
not very busy it's more interesting kind
of standing on in a gossip than actually
looking after to the
customers with you and you that was my
one big concern what's the point having
all those staff when they're not looking
after cust
customers seems to be a different person
that comes I don't know someone
responsible for Chopsticks and
somebody's responsible for clearing
generally get one one wait one waitress
or waiter it's not the way to have a
warm service you don't make customers
feel relaxed every time something hits
the table it's a new
waitress I'm looking for the best
restaurant on the daily basis with the
best food and the best service and I
want to see restaurants get better
despite the setback I'm pleased to see
you and you are still serving up
wonderful food nice nice crunchy apple I
thought the Apple would be a little bit
softer but it's nice and crunchy and the
bat is actually really light it tastes
really
nice that's a real strong element with
you and you they are constantly pushing
the boundaries out and they're trying to
reinvent Chinese cuisine but with her
21st century approach nice Nam Jim was
my Champion Tai from St Andrews in
Scotland it's it's a great restaurant
but my undercover cameras discovered
really surprising problems with
service
what ranks as about the most aggressive
service I've ever seen in my life with
my new secret D I get better treatment
you know the beef panang cor you don't
do like a chicken or a prawn version of
that you can do it yes you can do
chicken or pra yes could have pra
pra great flexibility from the dining
room staff um she didn't want the
chicken beef Curry she wanted prawns and
so they did it it wasn't even on the
menu the service is Miles better what
about the food when I went there I
discovered that some of the dishes were
slow in leaving the
kitchen it's not hot the sauce isn't hot
and the um the rice isn't very warm
either should be really hot when it
comes to the table damn food not piping
hot it was also a concern if food hangs
on the hot plate it shouldn't sit there
as it sits there the goodness is
disappearing but more more importantly
the food's getting
cold my best Spanish feno is the final
restaurant to stare elimination in the
face they barely put a foot wrong in
their
heat headchef Nas produces authentic
Spanish food that has impressed
everyone my undercover critic Simon
Davis is there to see if they've kept
their standards
up ah is that
theas
I've
probably
time in the top three yeah incredible my
cig din is blown away but listen to the
atmosphere in the background you know
it's buzzing and uh you can't buy the
atmosphere really good start but in his
main course my secret Diner detects
signs of over
seasoning
overing has been a little bit of a
heavy and first bit of negative feedback
for my secret Diner slightly clumsy on
the seasoning what a shame I've told all
four restaurants to expect my call they
know that I'm looking for Perfection but
only two will survive this stage it's
the moment of truth I am nervous whether
we've done enough I can't you I can't
answer that let's hope
so may I speak to Sam please how are you
S Bar how are you yeah not bad thanks
not bad hi um is that big time it is yes
how' you feel nervous
yeah unfortunately um the couple of
dishes were slightly heavy-handed with a
seasoning I'm deeply concerned about all
those
staff I want to see restaurants get
better and climb across this competition
and you and
you is not going to the next stage of
this competition all right really
sorry we didn't get through that's
all we do our
best stuffing is really my area and um I
think we lost lost it to go through to
the next round because of that right
matter all right just I think let you f
down
sorry standard toia you need to do your
best now
yeah Sam I'm sorry unfortunately I have
to eliminate two restaurants from this
competition and it's about to get even
harder for
feno cuz you're through to the next
stage of this competition
[Applause]
congratulations oh it's good my legs is
shaking now so it's good a it's a good
sign it's good
sign one Resturant is out and one has
survived my sudden death elimination now
I have to make one more very tough
call just very nervous I think you
wouldn't be right mind if you wasn't
actually nervous this situation to go
out at this stage would be very
upsetting next hello who will I pick to
join feno to fight for a place in the
final and whoever goes through will face
intense scrutiny the ultimate flying
visit from me and two Mystery
[Music]
Diners it's the first semi-final of my
Nationwide restaurant competition
Spanish heat winners feno have survived
my secret dining elimination now it's
down to my best Tai Nam Jim and my top
Italian Casmir one of them is about to
be knocked
out hello hi is that John R yes it is
hello Gordon
unfortunately I have to eliminate two
restaurants in this
competition you know this competition is
about searching Britain for the best
restaurant and I fell in love with n Jim
from the first minute I walked in there
oh thank you whatever happens after this
phone call you've got to
continue for n
Jim it's been an amazing journey
today is where it comes to an
end all right okay thanks
Daddy Jesus look listen I'm very very
proud everyone yeah they did though
so the competition is getting harder and
cemia
congratulations the next stage of
competition seriously really team I'm
than me the more sinks in yeah we feel
fantastic and uh yeah it's just
brilliant to feel appreciated and given
a chance to keep
going so two brilliant restaurants
remain in the first semi-final and I'm
going to pitch them both in a
head-to-head battle first I have a
surprise in
store I'm about to drop in unexpectedly
from meal on avanguard family run
Italian restaurant camir from
Bristol and modern Spanish tapers
restaurant feno from
London to help me decide who will make
it to the final I've enlisted two
trusted liut tenants for a second
opinion on strengths and weaknesses of
these two
restaurants Table 9 menu Prestige Angela
hartnet one of the most successful the
sheriffs of the last 15 years service
and Simon Davis one of my secret diners
an expert in putting restaurants through
their
Paces they know the restaurant business
inside out I trust their opinions
implicitly the C boys two very talented
young individuals beware it's not your
classic local Italian E3 let's go and
catch them off guard yeah
[Music]
totally
the first time I visited Casmir I found
their cooking to be new and exciting but
I discovered young chefs John Ray and
Peter sometimes push things too far and
their experimental dishes can be hit and
miss if you're trying to be Avant guard
you've got to go with your customers
you've got to take every customer
forward their parents Susan and PCO sank
their life savings into the restaurant
but it's their sons who caught all the
shots and cook exactly what they want
whether the customer likes it or not I
want to find out what Angela and Simon
think so we've caught them on the Hop
good evening how are you very well
welcome to C thank you hi guys how are
we how you doing thank you how are you
both you didn't expect us did you
ANG right look forward to seeing you
after thank
you Casmir are fully booked expectations
are high for top-notch food and service
it was still for you wasn't it yes
please thank you thank
you think this
sparkl Ste water do apologize thank you
very nervous I've already made a few
mistakes but which I don't normally do
but I think that's just nerves so I know
camir will be trying to impress me but
in a great restaurant everyone should
get special treatments so I've asked my
personal assistant and her partner to
dine here as well anonymously I'll find
out what they think later
11 in this restaurant diners literally
get what they given Casmir avangard nine
course tasting
menu for our fish course we're having
salmon cooked soused in a water bath
with cauliflower puree and a lemon
Emulsion I mean that's picturesque that
is Ravishing actually beautifully
presented plate of food delicious really
good they have great finesse next what
the menu refers to as a traditional
risoto thank you but true to form the
boys have given it their unique twist
using barley instead of rice and it's
toed with cold yogurt not Palm
I mean traditional is the wrong word you
can't call that a traditional risoto the
cold and the hot sensation I found it
just chilled the whole dish down for me
it's very sweet again you still find it
sweet thank you thank you my love thank
you quite defensive isn't
she you can't win everything you know
and that's it um there a taste and menu
there's certain dishes that people won't
like um hopefully they like all of them
and you know and some more than others
but uh that's it
really next course is lamb yet another
dish cooked in a water
bath it'll have a spar it'll have a spar
bath let go let's go for a bath going
for a
bath I'm a huge fan of the Sid method
but the real skill is understanding
which dishes it
suits you guys will correct me if I'm
wrong that's where svie cooking falls
down doesn't do it justice because that
Bloody world doesn't taste it very much
because it's been essentially so boiled
it's like a boiled lamb stew as opposed
to you know a cannon that warrants that
sort of nutty buttery slightly gy flavor
yeah damn what a shame finally it's time
for dessert an unusual take on a
traditional Italian pudding that starts
with an introduction from the boys our
earliest memory of good Italian cooking
was the dessert tiu given to us by our
father and takeaway cartons but you know
what the best bit here it says Sometimes
the best really is that simple Wow Let's
see the way people make bad turum is too
much alcohol and it's too sweet you've
got to taste that espresso through
it got the
coffee that is exceptionally good good
no it is good we've tasted some
outstanding Cuisine but some dishes have
fallen short technically um they're in a
their own yeah Stella really stellar and
you know really the top of their tree
but they need to cook for the punter the
moment they're cooking for themselves
they're cooking for their parents and
they're cooking for their hero chefs
it's always difficult with a family
restaurant but here more than anywhere
else chefs John Ray and Peter need a
strong guiding hand and their parents
aren't providing it I don't think they
giv the feedback you can't as a parent
you can't be that brutal you know you
can't be a manager and slap it down see
no one likes this time to call the
family together for a de breath
here's what we saw highs and lows
technically brilliant without a Shadow
of Doubt but you need to rain it in you
need to rain it in and understand it
from a customer's point of view not your
ambition because when the customers are
happy you're happy you're in business
customers are the power today and for me
the secret behind any good experience is
how everybody else feels in that dining
room and there's a second surprise
tonight cuz there's someone in that
dining room that means a lot to me
because she organizes my life life
Jennifer please darling and Michael how
was it overall it was an absolutely
fantastic experience we were made to
feel very special and we really enjoyed
our evening and we thought the chefs
were ingenious and talented and I think
at the end the tiasu wonderful 10 out of
10 really really good lovely thank you
my cover diners enjoyed their meal but
I'm still concerned over Susan and Paco
have they got it in them to run this
restaurant with a firm hand I love my
mom and dad's a bits I've said that
before but you know me and pet there's
no question about it we're ambitious as
hell we want to be in the same league as
Gordon Ramsey and Angela har one day we
I like to think we almost there but this
makes me more determined to win this
competition more than
ever as an overall experience going out
for dinner yeah it was it was it was
good but it can be great I have to slow
down and rain in a bit and if they can
control their ambition and focus on
their customers they'll surprise
themselves next is time to surprise
feno what we can't afford to do all
three of us is give them an easy ride
turn the plays upside down and really
put them under pressure
yeah so far this hugely successful
Spanish tapis restaurant has powered
through this competition Ty as we turn
up unannounced I hope they haven't let
their high standards
slip how are you are you well good to
see you like most lunchtime dinos we
want to be in and out in just 1 hour HF
n and owner Salon edti will have to
produce a perfect meal with speed and
efficiency it's going to be busy service
it's fully
book so it's going to be Qui
exciting we're going to dance in the
kitchen today we're here for a lunch and
we want to be treated like a normal
customer as you would do in which case
the best thing for us is to Edie and I
to leave you in the hands with one of
our normal waitresses and they can take
it from there unknown too my PA Jennifer
is also dining here and once again
she'll offer a secret perspective on the
restaurant's
performance thanks very is there a menu
um without being ripped a bit missing it
was all ripped a big hole in there sorry
sorry thank
you spit page one isn't it nothing
good one of the first dishes to arrive
is chipperoni deep fried baby squid
excuse me I have a plate please I
they're stumbling a bit aren't they they
are they're good but I tell you what
there is a way would hand with the salt
out there quite a lot of salt over
seasoning is once again a problem
Angela's Keen to get to the root of the
issue they not season it before you just
finish everything no with the Fe the
seasoning but always I like to have a
little bit more just a little bit extra
cuz the only one thing is the chiponis
we thought were a bit
salty every dish that goes up on the par
she puts extra salt and pepper on oh
really and I said to her finish it off
themselves she oh no but I add a bit
more each time wow which you don't need
to without tasting it well yeah not
tasting it just makes sense you got to
trust your Chef Serv we told the
restaurant that we're on an hour's
deadline but the mains still take 40
minutes to arrive just just dip your
finger up that's cold yeah that's
freezing damn this shouldn't be cold but
the problem with the pork belly is not
just the temperature is that all cardan
it's all cardan yeah that was too strong
wow far too many aren't there it's
really overpowering it's like going to
the dentist for anetic holy crap it's
not their finest hour no with that one
we have to leave in just 5 minutes and
still no one's taking our dessert orders
we're running very tight of time could
you recommend something quick free
desserts and um what would you I would
recomend maybe theat which is our
specialty which is like a
Spanish we're out of time we have to go
that's why I asked you to choose three
quick desserts no do 2 seconds please
I'd like the bill and I'd like samon
Eddie please thank you so
much damn that's a shame that's a
[Music]
shame I have to be honest I'm
disappointed cuz it's nowhere near as
good as it was last time round there's a
strand of over seasoning food that is
been cooked by the Brigade and
reasoned by the chef before it goes what
I'm more nervous about is the sloppy
service I think what's interesting is
looking around the room is um the tables
who obviously weren't trying to test
test out the service um you know cuz i'
I've seen with my own eyes was was good
and and the quality of the food was good
Eddie's bold claim is about to be put to
the test by my PA
Jennifer how was
lunch we have some mixed feedback we
felt that the welcome needed work the
STA seemed preoccupied at the beginning
and we felt a little
abandoned I thought that the stuffed
corette flour with the goats cheese was
a Triumph it looked pretty as a so and
The Taste was divine however towards the
end when the restaurant became extremely
busy unfortunately the service tailed
off and we began to feel neglected and
in fact our tea and coffee order was
forgotten I'm Sor to
[Music]
that we've said before we like to be the
best we like to win and obviously it's
it's not a great day when when it when
it goes wrong carpet's suddenly been
taken out from under our feet um and
that's not a a good fig
feeling my last experience here was near
Flawless and it was almost on the verge
of perfection that was
[Music]
embarrassing next oh Paco they've made
it this far but feno and Casmir are
about to go head-to-head in the ultimate
food challenge you can cook without a
[__] water bath let's get that right
yeah it's a Race Against Time yeah we CH
we're going to change G and there's only
one place in the
final in real shade
here great restaurants need to be
flexible and constantly evolved to
survive through these difficult times so
I want my semi-finalist Casmir and feno
to really prove to me they can create
something extraordinary Against All Odds
they both now face one grueling test for
a place in the final a challenge like
they've never ever experienced
before in just 12 hours they must turn
this bare shell into a thrilling vibrant
popup restaurant open for one night only
I want to see if my two semi-finalists
can create an amazing oneoff dining
experience with a tight budget and a
deadline it's Daybreak and I've called
both feno and Casmir to meet me here in
isington North
London good morning morning it's early
right and you're probably thinking what
in the hell am I doing
here and let's be honest it doesn't look
ra lamous does it no four bear w Bleak
yeah today you're going to
transform this boring somewhat cold
shell into the most amazing
unique popup
restaurant
forget your restaurant creates something
magical good
luck popup restaurants are one of the
hottest Trends in the food World they
spring up in unexpected locations cause
a big storm and then disappear overnight
there's the cash both restaurants will
have a 2,000 budget to split between
front of house for decor and the chefs
for
ingredients let's take 600 cuz I don't
want to be in a
[Music]
chef good luck guys had a shop
any they've only gotten until 7:00 p.m.
to create their restaurant from scratch
but up to 50 hungry diners who will
expect nothing think but the best so
many things we have to cook we have to
do we have to prepare it's going to be a
really really you know new
challenge I'm taking the chef to the
market and I'll be really fascinated to
see how this amazing produce gets their
creative juices flowing and they'll have
to really think on their feet and adapt
their menus based on what they
find first up The Butchers free- range
chicken fix Guinea F that PR what's
going through your mind cuz you got to
start coming up main course one of them
what is it going to be
okay you guys yeah I've got to get that
locked down pet we got to think about is
for the next five goddamn minutes
satday throughout this competition
Casmir have produced some amazing food
but some of it has been so experimental
it has missed the
Mark will they be tempted to show off
tonight or will they reain in for their
Diners right it's going to cost you P
but Peter and JRE are tempted by real
Rolls-Royce ingredient beef they love to
cook it Sous with a fragar parfait
served with popcorn thing is we're not
going to have
sorry there's not been a water bath
inside you can cook without a [__]
water bath let's get that yeah quite
easy so you got to come out of that
frame for a minute and and go back to
the beginning I want these boys to
forget some of their wild
experimentation tonight can they cook
something simple and perfect with no
[Music]
FRS
oh this is the B P yeah we we're going
to go for the B P
nice foo's head chef NZ Cooks fantastic
Spanish taas and pork features heavily
on their menu but I want to see if she
can go one step further and do something
extraordinary for this one night only
you're very comfortable with pork aren't
you we love we love Pork yeah and you do
as a main course starter or it's going
to be as a main course cuz they are the
cuts you we' got the most amazing line I
know I know but people love belly pork
mhm they love it you know chist
so hopefully hopefully I get right so 14
of those decision made pork belly a
great cheap cut good luck thank you very
much thanks is that a right thing to do
or is it but John R Peter still can't
decide between flashy beef or simple
pork I know it's a big decision man
going to be a [__] and time is running
out
fast feel it roosted slightly cure it
and then we plan for it let's do po
excuse me we're going to change it
change our change the change yeah we
change we're going to change Gordon
we're go back to our old Casmir routs go
with the port it's cheaper it's got
great flavor we have to work it harder
we have to work flavors our plan is to
cure it and then it'll be a bit so your
decision sorry to change your mind no be
pork where's the pork F sorry sir let's
go made a white decision I'm surprised
Casmir have gone for pork too but
they've chosen a Prime Cut as well as a
belly and I'll be fascinated to see what
both restaurants do with it one night
only let's see what they've given us a
successful restaurant isn't just about
fabulous food the front of house teams
must race against the clock to bring
their popup restaurants to
life cheaper I think that's nicer it's
cheaper and nicer they're working to a
tight budget and I want to see how
creative they can be I I personally
think that we ought to go no cloth and
wooden table samon EDI helped by one of
their managers kashka are going for a
simple Spanish feel I mean that's not
bad is it no I don't think the boys
would with that that helped by the
restaurant manager Anne Susan and PCO
are downstairs trying to choose Crockery
the boys will like is stressful is it
there are real Bargains to be had at 15
p a plate but they're scared it won't
meet the boys's high
expectations I'm feeling very
stressed I'm just worried we're not
going to get it all
done across London I'm taking the chef
to another of my favorite markets for
fish right now there this is a dream I'm
true for any chef because this produce
is
incredible is too much of a choice too
much choice just trying to get the right
the right fish doesn't get any better
than this nervz is drawn to the
delicious mackerel and wild sea bass
it's
incredible it's
amazing amazing amazing the wild sea
bass is an irresistible ingredient for
the young chefs from Casmir 2 excellent
decision done good in Chelsea Paco Susan
and Anne have decided to search for ples
in a department store but time is tight
and they'll have just 40 minutes to get
everything they
need excuse me could you tell me how
much those are each they're £5 each oh
my god do you do anything cheaper than
these or is this the cheapest here the
plate start from £2 each but Susan could
have got similar back at base for just
15 so if we could have 35 of these 35 of
these 35 of those it's a costly decision
spending more money on plates here means
a less to spend on the look of the
restaurant okay okay let me think let me
think should we just put some big
candles around we need some flowers as
well we need to get we got no money
we're in in real shed here what are we
going to put on the tables come on guys
we're rting what we going to put on the
table then let's take these then we
ain't got no choice okay so we can have
different colored ones I know the boys
are going to hate it but they're cheaper
and um we need to have some
ready one more that's f five of each
that's
please oh it's okay it's okay it's okay
s all right come on this
[Music]
is you're little bit stress out but this
that's Gordon promise Sweat and Tears
is come on I'm just come on we're going
to enjoy this I'm just tired and
stressed and I'm just worried about this
evening
will right it may not be the best
decoration and the best looking
restaurant in the world but the service
and the food are going to be
extraordinary okay so yeah think focus
on that okay
sus focus on that it's midday just 7
hours left for the teams to create their
pop-up restaurants back at base they
taking delivery of their furniture and
Crockery nice and that looks like a
Japanese
restaurant
oh Paco we've had it
now Susan's um out of depth they need to
understand that popup is a one night
only Mega experience and this is it show
off create those fireworks because
that's what's going to make your
restaurant win this competition stop it
let's just cut this [__] now guys we've
only got 3 hours right [__] it who cares
we're going to do it we're going to do
it well come on
then upstairs I get the sense that Posh
boy Sam and Eddie haven't been to Ikea
before and didn't realize that there at
natural wood tables come flat
packed the first one was 20 minutes
second one 15 minutes it's going to take
us an hour and again which is time we'd
much rather be doing something else and
also by the end of it we're going to
have blisters all over our hands but
never
[Music]
mind downstairs Paco and Susan are
working on the finishing touches I was
expecting this morning oh how is this
going to even look like a dining room
but we're getting there slowly with no
time to spare Sam and Eddie finally
Master their flat packed
tables I would give say high five but I
don't think so it is definitely
different to our restaurant but it still
captures what we are about the job do
I'm pleased with what we've done with it
I I can't believe that we've actually
made this horrible room and looking
somewhere where you much
better
yeah we're there just we are there it's
um you know it's been it's been a close
run thing this afternoon but we're
[Music]
sorted it's
7:00 cues of hungry diners wait to be
seated this morning I asked you to
create from scratch two stunning
restaurants yeah four bare walls two
empty shell one kitchen the pressure is
on
guys and in 3 hours
Time One Restaurant is leaving this
competition and one restaurant is going
through to the
final they have just 3 hours to impress
with a thrilling oneoff dining
experience my brother s how are you okay
wonderful hope you haven't been waiting
to long and that experience should start
as soon as people walk in and welcome to
the popup
restaurants of three just a tomato
mozarella salad tomato
mozzarella okay Casmir restaurant check
on table four you've got the first order
in in 5 minutes Susan you're feeling
okay wow AR she smiling nice one mom
table one all right one suit one what I
have to say I'm impressed I've had my
doubts whether mom Susan can run a
restaurant with a firm hand but tonight
she seems determined to prove me
wrong they've come together at the right
time and we know it's not how you start
it's how you finish but great
[__] come on keep this adrenaline
rushing Casmir are already busy taking
orders leaving feno plane catchup mael
pleas followed by the
[Music]
belly the mael star with thank you but
as their first orders reach the kitchen
already there's a problem what what's up
what's he do
[Music]
[__] next bar please it's the service
of their lives I know we don't have them
in the menu near can we do it let's just
let's just give it let's just [__] go
for it only one will
survive the restaurant going through to
the
final
is it's the semi-finals of my Nationwide
restaurant competition and it's Spain
versus Italy feno from London and Casmir
from Bristol they've created pop-up
restaurants from scratch and at the end
of tonight's service I'll decide who
goes through to the final Casmir
restaurant check on table before nice
one M great [__]
start but feno's kitchen has ground to a
halt HF n can't decipher Salon Edd's
handwritten checks what's that sorry
apologize struggling I mean they really
are struggling and um they don't seem as
jailed as they should be service please
the Casmir boys have created two
amazingly simple starters on their menu
a delicious fresh tomato jam salad with
mozzarella dusted in Parmesan guys I
need to hear like you're [__] hanging
off a cliff shatting for your life
service service come on fantastic food
but served in a soup bowl yeah I think
the bowl is the
Bow's this is really good though first
taste of the foods um ladies what did
you have salad salad the mozzarella was
very nice served in a
you would have invol their second
starter is a rustic Paris mushroom soup
what table number is that uh that is
table five so you got more soup in there
than they have in there same table they
have to be the exact same size I'm
watching
everything no one ever gets mushroom
soup right I could
have good and that was the best soup you
ever tasted best mushro it was almost
sort of foamy like loose or something
really creamy and delicious but it's not
everyone's
liking I just think it's too cold you
want me to warm it up for you yeah just
give me two seconds I'll be straight
back okay in the past I found doting mom
Susan usually leaps to her son's defense
on any criticism of their food One
customer is complaining you just like
get a bit warm now yeah no problems but
tonight it's great to see her treat her
sons like chefs not children just say
yes right away 2 minutes okay okay thank
you very
much I love phenos Spanish infused
starters succulent baby beetroot salad
with walnuts and Stilton and a
spectacular mackerel dish with grapes
and apple
[Music]
salad the macel and the fish was
beautifully cooked and the flavor of the
grapes went really well with it these
dishes are feno at their best but under
this intense pressure Nas needs to make
sure every plate is perfect I thought it
was a bit saltier really The Taste on
the plate was salt so
[Music]
girls a little bit of feedback one table
I just overhearing them a little bit
salty they said on on the start of the
mackerel what was the mael ma one
table so 1 hour in Foo are falling
behind they got a really [__] start not
only that but food's coming back and the
macel is salty which is a common thread
across feno we got to pick up the speed
uh pick up the gear pick up the
standards you know but this will get
better onto the mains and N has his plan
is to knock the dino socks off with the
wonderful flavors of a Fino classic
belly of pork with red wine sauce now
that pork looks
[Music]
fantastic CRA crispy she's also cooking
an amazing wild sea bass with Squid
wrapped in smoked Panetta it's almost
perfect but with little else but fit on
the plate I worry it lacks balance and
needs some garnish it was absolutely
delicious but missing a bit of car baby
potatoes yes we don't have baby potatoes
in the menu
I know we don't have them in the menu
near what I'm trying to do to make her
happy she wants potatoes can we do it
yes if we can do them Chef please I
think you'll sort out a situation okay
my one concern with the bass was no
starch on there the rich sauce the squid
it needs a you know it needs something
along those lines but we can boil
potatoes it takes 6 or 7 minutes I love
the way feno are doing everything they
can to please their
customers three santiagos one fig
please these are like the most delicious
potatoes potato
potato Pete how long two b one p you
said 2 minutes 2 minutes ago uh there'll
be about five uh 4 minutes yeah 5
minutes I've got it in othering go for
it I've got it in other
man back in the kitchen John Ray and
Peter are also serving pork but they're
mixing belly with prime cup fet top with
Italian
garnishes
CET the boys are also creating a
fantastic Italian sea bass with
canellini beans I love it because it's
so simple no wild avangard Frills for
this
dish you're going to enjoy
that I had the Seas for my main course
the skin was crispy this the fish was
cooked perfectly table one M cor back
said that was the best piece of fish
she's ever had in her
life f are finishing with a classic
Spanish dessert sanago tart could this
popular sweet be their winning
touch oh that
yeah I'm not a dessert person I thought
the flavors of the Almond was really
lovely and the tart thank you Ladi this
this is me
again the goodl looking
one for their dessert John Ray and Peter
are serving a modern Italian take on
apple crumble with almond infused
custard but they've added a Twist that's
leaving some of my diners
confused the Apple's kind of like
lukewarm but the rest of it is very cold
I'm just not
sure is it supposed to be warm or cold
slightly warm because too hot the flavor
can be
affected cir's apple crumble is meant to
be eaten warm but it's leaving some
customers
cold it was a bit standard I'm afraid
the rest of the meal was amazing the
dessert did let it down a little bit 10
p.m. and service is
over tonight the diners decided how much
to pay they Lov both restaurants so the
Tans were equal but this challenge
wasn't simply about
money well done thankks sh a tough 12
hours it was a battle against time and
pressure to create a thrilling dining
experience for one night
only we put our heart and soul into this
evening the kitchen have put their heart
and soul into it and I just think uh
we're going to
win I mean I I believe we had the edge
today to be in um the final of of
Ramsey's best restaurant would be a
culmination of you know kind of a a lot
of hard work it'd be amazing it' be
absolutely fantastic thanks bye I'm so
happy because both restaurants seriously
push the boat out and the hard part for
me right now is that I have to make a
decision between those two
[Music]
restaurants
this has
been one of the toughest challenges I've
ever
[Music]
set there were times that I honestly
didn't
think both restaurants were going to
make
it and I started to panic
and as the clock ticked away the
restaurants just started emerging
becoming individual restaurants with
identity
character the atmosphere in both
restaurants
amazing the
food stunning and on the back of the
last 3 hours you've made it incredibly
difficult for me
[Music]
to
decide on which restaurants going
through to the
final that's what a popup restaurant is
all about a one-off one night only
unique
experience and on the back of that
performance it's such a close
call based on everything I've seen these
guys definitely understand flavors let's
see how the Cucumber goes all this yeah
weird tast a little bit of
heavy everything I tasted that's
delicious lovely it's a proper Spanish
dish that's pictures beautifully
presented plate of food everything I've
listened to Casmir restaurant check on
before nice one mom to make her happy
she wants potatoes come can we do it yes
if we can do them Chef
[Music]
please the restaurant going through to
the
final
is
cmir yes yes
[Music]
yes
well done thank you well done you can
smile you can
smile thank you well done well
done for us it was a new you know new
challenge so it was really tough
obviously disappointed but I mean the
guys they are
amazing love you cir are in the fin
because they understood for the first
time in this competition what customers
want John Ray and Peter dropped the
frails and they delivered I think
they're amazing it's incredible we've
got two little Geniuses but my God can
they
cook [__]
impressive tonight four amazing
restaurants will battle it out for a
place in the final of my best restaurant
competition
and it's the mother of all battles with
the winners of the British Indian North
African and French Heats facing sudden
death elimination I'm going to be
testing them to Breaking Point the table
has just coming in the serial
complainers the two surviving
restaurants will go on to face an
onslaught of tough challenges this space
now
becomes your
restaurants who will go through to the
[Music]
final
last week Bristol's culinary Wizards
camir triumphed in the first semi-final
well done you can smile now four
resturants will compete in the second
semi-final for a chance to take on
Casmir in the Grand
Final competing for that place The Best
of British sheffields the
Milestone Indian winners from Bradford
pessard my best North African AO from
London and finally winner of the French
heat winam fields from
Lincolnshire first I want to know if
they've corrected the problems that I
identified earli in the competition you
need to look at your service to help me
find out I sent in a team of secret
diners what is in that hor but there's a
big surprise in store for these
restaurants I'm going to throw two of
them out right now it's sudden death
elimination which two restaurants Will
Survive first to face possible
elimination are French winners
windingham
fields headchef and owner Colin is
aiming for the ultimate fine dining
experience he's created a luxurious
dining room and serves Exquisite
food but I thought Colin was trying too
hard overloading his diners with too
many appetizers and too many waiters 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 boo anymore look all
you guys just check there's no one in
here H don't know with their PL in the
final at stake I've since sent in
another secret Diner Rob Allison an
expert foodie with a critical
eye and I've sent all my semi-finalists
their own copy of the footage so that
they know what I'm judging them on this
is a second appetizer or moose B um
sometimes these little touches get too
much and I've ordered my meal I want my
long scenes I've told
Colin endless times less is more
and here we go again thank you thank you
perfect thank you this dish looks AB
delicious but it's not
[Music]
mine really perfectly cut long steam
this beautiful I the mix up on the the
starter I mean disaster um I mean it
happens probably 1% of the time and and
guess what it's him yeah it's just not
good enough next to face undercover
scrutiny our Indian winners prad from
Bradford please Mom Ki and
daughter-in-law minel produce some of
the best food I've ever eaten and it's
all vegetarian that is delicious one
mouthful of that I feel like I'm back in
Mumbai now I can't leave that to waste I
got to eat some more of that I'm sorry
Jesus Sun Bobby runs front of house with
charm and warmth Cheryl farmer is a food
expert with 20 years experience I'm
expecting her to love love this place as
much as I
did but when she went in under cover
Bobby wasn't anywhere to be seen instead
another member of staff was running
front of house seems like the man's
rushed off to go back to uh go back to
his
cocking been nice to been offered a
drink that probably wasn't it right
nobody asking the secret diner for
drinks and they just left alone I mean
this doesn't even look like the same
restaurant
a bit of sound proofing on the kitchen
it's nice to wear kind of chatter in the
background but you don't hear people
scraping the pans
out you can hear this kitchen Porter by
the sound of things beating the hell out
of his pant cleaning this looks like a
completely different restaurant the food
was really lovely it was um other the
dishes were really nice and spiced my
secret diners love the food um thank
God because they're not enjoying the
service Gordon's going to absolutely
crucify me it's about getting it right
every time the contrast from that
footage in comparison to what I received
last time it's night and
day next to face my video evidence is a
zoo from
London in the North African heat Hef
Chris produced some wonderful authentic
Algerian food sardines and
hmer they're delicious mer see
but my coach trip exposed some
weaknesses front of house and table four
can you remember what he
did that's done
twice I've sent in undercover critic
Simon Davis to see if Chris has ired out
his front of house problems and is still
sending out perfectly cooked food that's
the chicken man little bit dry the
chicken damn disappointing chicken
slightly overcooked
dry question um actual sauce absolutely
lovely I mean actually one of the nicest
things I've tasted simple charming and
delicious but they have to be consistent
finally it's the Milestone from
Sheffield run by four ambitious young
men this restaurant is Reinventing
classic British food but they made
errors when my last secret Diner paid a
visit you eat
that would you eat that no so why should
I use it to progress in this competition
I need to know the Milestone team are
learning from their mistakes
this is nice it's really um quite a nice
really nice texture and it goes really
nicely with the cing seeds in the flat
bread let's start with a little freebie
um homemade humus with cumin and
flatbreads thank you next up it's play
vets fish it serve with a lemon pith
puree what is in that a
T lemon
place is a delicate fish and it needs
help acidic certainly but not maybe
lemon Pi slightly bitter abundance
St one girl
table fck sake my one problem with
Milestone is their lack of experience
can they get better I'm I'm
uncertain all four restaurants are
waiting with batty bread for a phone
call from
me they know that two of them are about
to leave the
competition so
tense it's all on this phone call
[Music]
really how rest time help you hi is that
Chris oh M hi Simon hello Gordon how are
you I'm bar think how are you I'm good
I'm a little bit stressed um but I'm
well unfortunately today I have to
eliminate two restaurants from the
competition
yeah there's only one waitress trying to
take care of eight or 10 tables you've
got to match the food with the service
right
yeah mixed grill was a little bit too
dry and the chicken was overcooked
[Music]
AO
right it's not going any further in the
competition that's no problem thank you
very much I'm sorry no worries but
continue doing what you're doing will
you okay thank you
mer say it stops here it's really
disappointing for not winning I I'm like
GED I wanted to win this competition
with My Soul I'm taking a
[Music]
break not going to get easier Simon I am
really
sorry but you guys are going to have to
keep on working incredibly hard the next
round
[Applause]
of oh my
God congratulations oh cheers going just
I've just had a hard time well done take
care thank you
byebye I can't put into words how much
it means to me personally it's the
biggest thing I've ever done in my
career next Bradford's Pasad and Link's
winteron Fields find out who else is
leaving the
competition whoever goes through will
face my next challenge a surprise
dropping from me and two diners from
[Music]
hell it's the second semi-final of my
Nationwide restaurant
competition AO are out and British heat
winners the Milestone have survived my
Southern death
elimination they will now compete for a
place in the final against either my
best Indian
prashad or my best French restaurant
winteringham
Fields hi is that Colin yes it is hi
Bobby it's Gordon hi Gordon
Bobby I'm pissed off
yeah I have to eliminate two restaurants
from this
competition
[__] when I saw those plates getting put
uh down to the wrong uh position I I got
so frustrated cuz I could have
screamed then you've got that level of
support in the dining room should be
absolute
perfection you've really Sha up until
now and you have to focus in that
restaurant on a daily
basis
yeah windingham
[Music]
field is leaving the
competition okay I'm sorry
[Music]
right okay take care goodbye
byebye bit gutting cuz I know we are you
know so much better than than that but
that's consistency for you know you need
to be you know bang on every time all
the
time right now you need to
focus because you're going through to
the next
[Music]
stage oh my good good good good Bobby I
will never ever let you down again
congratulations thank you thank you so
much thank you bye-bye
byebye they need to focus now and he's
been given a lifeline and the
restaurants across the board is too good
to leave this
competition two fantastic restaurants
remain both desperate for a place in the
final now I've got a big shop for them
oh my
God I'm about to pay a surprise visit to
my two remaining semi-finalists to help
me decide on who should go through to
the final I've enlisted two trusted
lieutenants for a second opinion on the
strengths and the weaknesses of these
amazing restaurants Michelin starred
Chef Angela hartnet needs no
introduction and undercover D of Simon
Davis a top restaurant critic and a
confirmed
carnivore it's time to surprise press
art in Bradford this is the smallest
restaurant in the competition but they
have the biggest heart I know they'll
fight tooth and nail for a play place in
the final and after letting my secret
Diner down they'll need to how did they
react to it mortified really mortified
I'll throw the lifeline cuz I really
believe in these guys and today it's
going to be nothing less than
perfect today Pasad will need to pull
out all the stops to impress us but they
have absolutely no idea that we're about
to walk through the
door m
M hello yeah how are you very good how
are you didn't expect to see me did you
no I didn't know have a seat angel
please thank you oh when I heard his his
here I was so nervous and oh I get
panicking you
know I've just found my my first bug
bear that Bloody door alarm anyone steps
in welcome to pad thank you thank you
very much very very privileged to see
you actually any drinks for you I'll
have the mango the mango Lassie mango
lass as well please thank you I'll have
it for Luda okay right thank you thank
you nice warm reception welcoming I know
prad will be trying to impress me today
but every customer needs the same
treatment so I've got another trick up
my sleeve Angela's mom Juliano is here
too she's also a fantastic chef and
she'll be a secret extra pair of eyes
and ears and Bobby we're up against it
time W today I got 90 minutes so we
could set the order as quick as possible
thank you so much
we're hungry and we want to try as much
of this food as possible so we're going
to bombard the kitchen with orders I'd
like to go for the um Masala DOA bar
Kebab we have the PE pach churry and
then maybe some pu as well the chlie the
special sh corn roll as well please
anything else you'd recommend Masala
doer best doser I had was in Delhi so
far when try one yeah give me a masala
doser yeah do that perfect you can
compete with Deli guys listen yeah I
don't want any mistake this is a big
order
go manal is focused on my table but will
she pay as much attention to Angela's
mom in a great restaurant every Diner is
a VIP one person mushroom now Qui Qui I
need now come on hurry up what the H are
you doing quit panicking you don't need
to panic you don't need to be Lous we're
on fire this is prashad this is what we
do okay hey is
my they very vocal in I mean very very
focal mom medium chat anybody have no
shouting is fine as long as it produces
results I need
fies order is ready
now thank you lovely thank you Simon
thank you thank
[Music]
you the contented silence at our table
speaks
[Music]
volumes excellent Absolut delous I'm
really good fantastic and I'm amazing
Carnival wow that's delicious is it I
really is dish after dish is delivered
with charm Angelo that she zuchi and
chadal with no coriander thank you each
one hitting way above the mark go isn't
that
fantastic smells amazing it just looks
so grand grand authentic and smells
amazing it's like a
[Music]
banquet that is absolutely delicious
good that phenomenal I think abs
it's exceptional Vegetarian Cuisine mom
m oh my God they're loving the
food who's missing meat not
me it's time to give Pasad a collective
appraisal so um I was a little bit
nervous coming back today to be totally
honest Angela how was it for you oh no
for me phenomenal food absolutely
phenomenal blown away I thought it was
so good mad DOA oh as good as the one I
had in Delhi yeah it was brilliant
absolutely Simon the stuff you do just
you know beggar belief that cofa with
that cauliflower is just it's a
revelation yeah um food today Flawless
outstanding lovely warm service but
we've been watching everything I mean
every table and there's another surprise
because we have an extraordinary lady
here Mrs Harnet andel's
mom
Mrs see this lady taught me how to cook
and her mother taught her how to cook
G what did you honestly think Mom did
you no fabulous food I love those balls
with potatoes and D everything is
perfect and Bobby the service wonderful
yeah wonderful thank you very much thank
you thank you we so pleas you are here
good would you come back oh God
yes today was about Redemption and you
certainly redeemed yourselves and this
whole experience will help me decide on
who's going through the final uh thank
you for a delicious delicious lunch can
you do something with that door yeah
please that alarm thank you thank
you you know three heavy weights in the
food industry turning up to an ex La r
in the middle of Bradford um looking for
fault been demanding been difficult and
could we find fault no we're back on
track we're back there I think we're
going to go and
win my other semi-finalist is the
Milestone okay on the way to Sheffield
how will they cope with a three us
dropping in for a surprise dinner four
guys that don't give up on anything they
rear their own pigs they make their own
bread they turn their own butter and
they really are pushing the boundaries
out beyond belief so uh I think it'll be
impressed put the Water Crest on very
last as it's going since I first met
these Young Guns they've impressed me
with their mixture of classic and
creative British dishes it's about York
people York shest producing yorkish food
but they also run a cooking school and
an outside cun company as well as the
restaurant
and I can't help but feel they're trying
too
hard straight upstairs yes with so many
fingers and so many pies sometimes
they''re falling short of
perfection guys how are you good to see
you again likewise you didn't expect to
see us did you no in Simon tonight I'm
with two very influential guests and
we're going to be looking at everything
t for three there's a table has just
comeing in the serial complainers they
go everywhere and they just slate you no
matter what
this evening's dinner menu for you thank
you the adrenaline's pumping he's he's
the main man isn't he so he's the
person's been impressed I know that we
focus on me and my guests but how will
they treat Angela's sister Anne who's
eating on the other side of the dining
room it red a lot more elaborate than I
had the impression of from you guys yeah
just things like parmesan Noy wild M and
canone quirky it's not your average soil
and shoot snow they're push the yeah
yeah big time yeah I just hope it's
tastes as good as it sounds actually it
does seem nice and
seasonal head jef Simon and suf James
have made their Mark by Breaking All the
Rules serving up local ingredients with
a quirky twist for our starters we've
ordered black pudding with bacon pepper
mackerel with horseradish snow and a
tomato consum with a flour pot full of
tapenade for soil and peases is there an
earthquake is that your hand shaking
shaking simmer than you Sim
I I feel like we're at V bend the flower
pot yeah
exactly it's very hard to eat a soup and
navigate your way around
a things like this I just want to thrb
at the shf or get his head and go it's
just gimmick isn't it yeah I'm GL to see
how it
[Music]
tastes what is that that is tapar how
much tapar can you put in a dish like
that I mean I know that's the soil but
bloody hell that doesn't make sense too
much soil less is more and this is all
they need to know less is
[Music]
more they're Keen as mustard I mean
really Keen but far too ambitious for
their own good the minute you start
trying to become too clever you're up
for intense scrutiny not going to like
to affect it main course is
next for our Mains we've got more
[Music]
conventional salmon wrapped in a herb
crust vegetarian canalon and bavet of
beef I mean they're attractive looking
dishes I mean I like the presentation I
actually think this is a really well
sourced meat well cooked well handled if
I had any criticism it would be the red
wine Jew cuz it's really sweet it's
almost the consistency of neat
rbo how's your um
Calon it's actually very nice mushrooms
delicious yeah they can cook but they
just need to rain it back
in finally it's time for pudding a tree
of strawberry desserts Bakewell tart see
that looks nice that looks good and a
great local cheese board see that and
that fits this thing here looks like
it's out of Paris Hilton's bathroom it
doesn't make sense no really good it
looks delicious and it tastes delicious
and R ice cream really
this looks great that's actually the
best thing I've eaten tonight this one
here yeah that's actually
nice time to call the team together for
a
debrief can I just say that was
delicious really good and unfortunately
didn't start like that if there's one
strong message you're trying too bloody
hard I've tasted the greatness and
tonight has been a disappointment stick
to what you're good at doing yeah and
for me the secret of any good restaurant
is how every other table is been looked
after and tonight there's a second
surprise we've actually got Angela's
sister having dinner with as
well come over come over
James so how was your night an mixed
mixed I didn't really like the bread I
thought the bread was a bit heavy and I
like the Tomato thing I have to say but
I love all that and what was your stter
James I had the pudding it was quite
sticky and quite quite heavy so don't
worry about trying to be too different
when you're good at what you do get back
to what you're good at doing and stick
to that thank you very much good luck
with everything
[Music]
yeah [__]
me feel like I've been told off by my
dad valid points so yeah it's well it's
constructive so we have to take it on
chin and do what we can with it it's
main thing
yeah I'm disappointed because I came
back to the milestone for a magical
experience hoping they'd learned but
they just want to be different tonight
was a big
disappointment coming up I challenged my
semi-finalist to create a restroom from
scratch the tables look great yeah yeah
the restaurant looks [__] and tempers
flare as the pressure pushes them to the
very edge
so she can't polish the table no she she
can't relay it no
[Music]
wow two amazing contenders prashad from
Bradford and the Milestone from
Sheffield are fighting to win the second
semi-final of my restaurant
competition we want to serve every
single customer like we do at home quick
now now now now now later tonight one of
them will make it into the final and
have the chance to be crowned my best
restaurant bashad and milestone once
again I've survived my secret diners and
a flying visit which really turned both
their restaurants upside down they both
now face one more grueling test for a
place to the final a challenge that
they've never faced
before I've called prad and the
Milestone to meet me in North London
good morning morning morning you're
probably thinking what in the hell are
we doing here this early in the morning
standing in a pretty
unimpressive room yeah and look at it
bare
Bleak this space now
becomes your
restaurants and you're going to
transform these four walls into the most
amazing popup restaurant only one
restaurant's going through to the final
make sure it's
you I'm giving each of them one floor of
this empty building they've got just 12
hours to create an exciting exciting
vibrant pop-up restaurant that will open
its doors at 7:00 p.m. for one night
only popup restaurants are one of the
hottest tickets in the food World they
spring up in unexpected locations cause
a big storm and then disappear overnight
both restaurants will have a £ 2,000
budget it will be split between the
chefs 500 is enough and front of house
you want to feel like you're in a
wedding you want to feel like you're in
a party you've got to make and create
that atmosphere the challenge is massive
neither restaurant has done anything
like this before it will push them to
the very limits of their creativity and
their Ingenuity M players we need to
decide on play the decisions they make
now could cost them a place in the final
wow love that table oh requires assembly
a time a
pissing the chefs are heading to some of
London's best markets to choose their
ingredients for tonight's menu Simon and
James are looking for fantastic meat to
wow their diners we're looking towards
the thick end of the pork belly so I
want people to enjoy what they're
getting good quality pork cheeks pork
liver yes pork liver and mint the
Milestone prizes itself on serving
amazing classic British food that's all
the P cheeks we got after that
disappointing flying visit they'll need
to prove to me that they can deliver
great food plate after plate the people
are going to see something different I
think we're doing it right
there coconut yes f is a hard noise it's
a good one Ki and Manel are in the
element in the vegetable market for the
perfect vegetarian restaurant you need
perfect vegetables and here's the place
Vine Tomatoes Vine tomatoes one box over
there prad serve up some of the most
delicious and exciting food I've ever
tasted this challenge will show me if
they have the potential to develop their
restaurant and Thrive outside their
comfort zone but you know got 50 guests
coming yeah yeah it doesn't look like
this enough three box it will be enough
enough yeah okay
good the chef's head back to base
while they're front of house teams make
their final purchases let's get then is
there yeah but have a look at got 60 of
those see that in the glass yeah yeah so
eight of these yeah eight of those pleas
that's the exact idea we're looking for
this is prad's chance to create an
incredible interior a million miles away
from their simple Bradford Cafe so we're
going to get some of this one then how
much you want 3.8 M of the other one can
I get 5 m of the red if I get rid of the
red you can have 3 and 1/2 M of each of
these can I have 5 m of both of those
and I'm canceling the red
the chefs have just 6 hours to create
culinary
magic going to be show can turn these
humble ingredients into something truly
spectacular on the
plate to compete pad will need to make
the vegetarian menu really s when you
make the curry hard to make it because
we're making so
fresh they getting getting on with it
and still we are preparing so yes I am
little bit nervous we don't want to
panic when you do the Panic then you
always do the mistake these dishes
include baked yam and potatoes with
spiced coconut and peanut filling
vegetable pilow rice and stuffed baby OB
jein so you cut them in half yeah and
you stuffed them with the reserve Masala
Masala yeah
nice I want both restaurants to amaz and
Delight my diners I don't want carbon
copies of prad or the
Milestone okay you're on Lo the van now
yeah yeah we're opening just done 4
hours from now you know that yeah give
me a feel prad what are they doing
what's the what's the objective the
objective is to give a wedding fair to
give you a little bit of a taste of the
Asia wow good luck thank
you quite a complicated table not
planned for
um oh my goodness uh it gets more
complicated as we go along okay guys
we're opening just under 4 hours yeah
yeah get going as soon as gon walked in
it dawned on me what was ahead of
us we've got to perform we don't to let
the lads down in the kitchen they're
going to do their side we need to make
sure we do our side so there's a lot of
pressure on us with the amount of time
we've got fingers crossed we will
literally just be ready Bobby has been
bold with his plans for the space I hope
he has time to put it off Under Pressure
still not getting any further forward
with these
tables mess I know we're pushed for time
yeah yeah but just run downstairs pop
your head downstairs very
quickly all right looking
[Music]
fantastic okay they're looking in a
pretty good shape aren't they they are
and this is looking like a campsite the
biggest mistake we' made is we didn't go
for ready made TBL right now we're sort
of on our second table yeah getting put
together we're opening in just under 3
hours from now and I you know we' got
lot to do yeah yeah what are they uh
Cuttery Jesus where'd he go a [__]
Camp shop we were we're trying to go
with the with the look and the feel of
the tables and match everything with the
whites and the blacks Jesus
wow he's [__] not impressed is
he Gard bobb's in a mess and
um it looks Dreadful um pretty crap
knife and forks and Dreadful tables like
they've been hanging around outside a
pub can't see the end in sight so quite
nervous this see 2 hours 2 hours is a
long time there's
no we didn't come all this way to lose
cuz we couldn't build
tables downstairs the Milestone are much
happier with their tables but they
haven't paid any attention to the rest
of their
space the tables look great yeah yeah
the restaurant look [__] there's no
thought process with the tarting up four
walls I'm interested in a stunning
Resturant yeah that's what I would like
to see yeah but have we got any Fabrics
no cushions or no orate pieces of
furniture to liven up no this is it the
idea of a popet restaurant yeah it's not
just the location but it's a Shoff
aspect you mean you rear your own pigs
you make your own bread and come in the
dining room it's like I know what you
guys are like when you use your
imagination so I give you the
flexibility to go and do something out
the box
okay what a
shame [__]
up it's a one night only 2,000 to create
something exciting and magical and the W
Factor Milestone are going for something
simplistic they've played it safe but
that may not get you into the
final there's no lack of ambition in the
kitchen however Simon and James are
serving sarec and skate scampy with a
silver mullet and bra oxtail accompanied
by English squash and wild mushrooms
that's your oil yeah so you should be
happy that's ciling time yeah tastes
delicious really nice it's not over 10
that's if they pull this food off it
will be
amazing what's this one here peas in
there is a m
pan peas and pan
that's delicious that's
[Music]
delicious things are taking shape two
tables are done time is on our hands you
got all the cut on the table for both
courses uh no we've haven't unwrapped it
yeah do you care Bobby I care a lot B
you do I I'm worried [__] Cutlery Plain
Jane dying room and I know you can do
better I'm really
sorry with very little time left before
Pasad open their doors Ki goes upstairs
to the dining
room we have made some errors you know
uh but we can't constantly focus on them
we can't change those errors right
now it's okay SC
yeah
yeah I'm sure you will do it this is it
it [__] a bust if it goes bad we're back
to Sheffield we've done the best we can
but we're here to win it listen to me
yeah every part of what we do is with
our heart we're a 22 seat restaurant
working our guts off if we're not good
enough we're not good enough we'll still
give it our best shot we're opening in
just under 5 minutes from now and this
is it everything they've worked for all
day depends on the service and I've
never had an evening that's been so
dependent on an amazing performance in
the kitchen because both restaurants
have been let down by the front of house
and it's up to the kitchen now to redeem
themselves in a big way and pull it back
next
my two restaurants feel the heat in
their pop-up restaurants but which one
will have the edge to win a place in the
final quick now now now now now you can
get chippy with me so she can't polish
the table no wow yeah the restaurant
going through to the
final
[Music]
is it's 7:00 and outside the puppet
restaurant's being run by my 27 finalist
cues of hungry diners wait to be seated
when those customers arrive blow them
away warm welcome a 3-hour
service but prove to me tonight why you
deserve a place in the final good luck
to both
restaurants each restaurant can seat 25
customers and if they can squeeze in a
second sitting they could serve as many
as 50 good evening my name is Bobby come
and have a seat
I want them to really impress me and
ensure my diners have a thrilling once
in A- lifetime dining
experience straight away Bobby and his
brother mayor are Charming their guests
the chefs have put together a theme
around a wedding we're a little family
restaurant we really want you to be an
extended part of our family and enjoy a
meal but are there diners hearing the
Indian wedding bells talk to me about
the decor I guessed it was a wedding and
I didn't read en two seconds later we
saw so I think they got it right it's a
bit sort of shabby
with the and the tables and stuff but
then the um sort of welcoming Etc was
really really
nice Bobby and his team are quick on the
draw and start taking orders
three
thank downstairs is a different story 15
minutes into service and the Milestone
still haven't taken any orders Matt Mark
while you're gassing away get some
orders in here yeah they're not here for
the LIF sorry they're here for the
experience come
on it's driving me [__] insane dining
room is full and not one order into the
kitchen right Jay order on three ox tail
one poock first ticket in 25 minutes
later meanwhile prad's sumptious
starters yam and potato Puri and
marinated stuffed Leaf Parcels are
flying off the pass and are they
supposed to go at hot or room
temperature is that the right the right
temperature it is yeah it is okay good
it actually tastes quite nice it's quite
a subtle flavor Madam how's your yeah um
this one was good but this one I don't
know what is that white thing supposed
to be under
cooked
like I've never seen food like this
coming from you both it's raw taste your
food and stop
rushing sorry sorry don't be sorry to me
be sorry to your guest yes we want to
serve every single customer like we do
at home okay good luck darling I love
you Dreadful start delicious filling but
what's the point in putting in between
two slices of raw yam three belly one
mullet at last the Milestone boys are
getting the food out yes Che That's it
[Music]
man but there's mixed reviews
this is really
nice but it slightly needs a bit more I
had the cured poet for my St it was all
together quite delicious
just the first two tables food looks
amazing needs seasoning first two
tables thankfully minel and Ki are
starting to hit their stride their
Punjabi main courses of delicious mutter
paneer peas with Indian curd cheese and
amazing spice stuffed obene are going
down a storm uh the oine and
potato a pan dish was actually really
really nice um full of flavor spicy it's
full of full of vend in the kitchen the
Milestone boys are in full flow serving
their Mains of pan-fried silver mullet
and pork cooked
[Music]
threeways
text very very starters went out and it
was a disaster now the main courses are
going out and it seems to be a lot more
settled and more
controlled outside more hungry diners
are waiting for the meal of their
lives now we should start to be thinking
of turning those tables yeah okay now
there's a queue outside for Pasad
experience I don't want them in the
freezing cold nor do you back upstairs
tabls relay and keep that energy in the
dining room
please
with just an hour of service left the
Milestone are starting their second
sitting
I'm but upstairs prashad seemed to have
lost all urgency leaving hungry diners
waiting outside in the cold at this rate
there won't be enough time before
closing to take an extra sitting come on
come on you got to work and talk at the
same time I'm sorry you know it's almost
like it say uh D it's not everyone's
giving up come on come on come on come
on unless the whole family pulls
together no one else will be eating in
Pasad tonight me now caly can you go
upstairs and help clear the tables
please yeah
please we've got just under 1 hour to go
okay so can you go upstairs and polish
the table so we get some more tables sat
down don't go upstairs you guys I'm
telling them to do it yeah because you
need help the listenable there's nothing
to do so I'm asking them to give you a
hand and you'll get an arrogant and say
no please go
upstairs clean the
tables
you can get chippy with me yeah I'm
asking them your mom to go upstairs and
help you you get defensive I do yeah
because we don't like her to do those
jobs we do those jobs the table don't
clear the table yourself we'll clear it
so she can't polish the table she she
can't relay it no wow yeah he cracked
Under Pressure clearing tables away and
trying to set customers that are
standing outside in the cold um it's
difficult to have that level of
arrogance and get it thrown in my face
like that you know that's that's his
cool but stay calm and deal with it um
I've stepped up and said to I shouldn't
probably said to Gordon you know he
knows exactly what should do what
shouldn't I'm really sad because I
respect that man to stand up to him like
that not clever Bobby has finally turned
some tables and Manel and Ki have fixed
the problems with their yam starters to
the Delight of prad's new
guest I've got an a yam dish and it's
it's really spicy and really tasty the
spice is not too hot it's just it's just
right it's lovely started [__] we can
finish strong come
on R them round finish strong rally them
round and finish strong come
on I can't help but want to approach you
and say sorry but it's not the
time come here come here I'm not here to
fight with you yeah I'm here to support
big day tough day everyone's under
[__] pressure you got 20 minutes left
pull it back will 20 minutes left pull
it
back Scamp here 10 seconds 10 seconds
can do yeah I love the way both Pasad
and the Milestone are now doing
everything they can to serve their Diner
wonderful food quick now now now no now
and both dining rooms are buzzing as the
final plates have been served best
course of the evening I've had and I'm
very impressed with that
delicious five okay four okay 3 2 one
and stop turn everything off please yeah
10: p.m. and service is over it's been a
long tough day for both
restaurants well done man I hope we won
this can't guarantee it there's no
guarantees in this um cuz I mean we
we've we've thought we've lost before
and we've won so we don't
know I know we didn't perform to the
level that we would normally a lot of
people didn't some people didn't like
the food come here come
on
[Music]
I have to really really protect my my
ladies we did everything the best
we I know I
know Pasad and the Milestone have
embraced this huge Challenge and have a
lot of satisfied
customers but both restaurants had
problems in their kitchens and front of
house you're welcome thank you great
job now I have to decide who deserves a
place in the
[Music]
final this has to be the toughest
challenge both restaurants have ever
faced quite
frankly from both restaurants I was
disappointed because I
knew that the personality is didn't
shine
tonight you undersold
yourselves
bashad I didn't see Bobby the face of
Pasad
tonight let's be
honest Milestone I felt that you spent
far too long getting those first three
or four tables in I'm standing
outside knocking get the orders in get
these guys out the
traps and on the back of your
performance and your performance let me
tell you it is so
difficult to gauge an outright
winner two phenomenal restaurants were
put on the spot
[Music]
today the restaurant going through
through to the
[Music]
final
is
[Music]
[Applause]
Bashan congratulations thank you very
much thank you
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
thank gutted really really gutted but
end of the day we did our best I'm still
proud of what we did uh really proud of
James the boys in the restaurant chin up
let's go get some
PE
here well done thank you yes good job
you're in the final and good luck thank
you thank
[Applause]
you what a final prashad versus Casmir a
small 20 seater vegetarian Indian
restaurant from Bradford up against
Young Guns the Michigan star boys TI for
the top [__] game on British
restaurants were once a laughing stock
not anymore today we have some of the
most exciting restaurants in the world
but which are the best and what are the
restaurants that you really love I asked
you and the response was amazing we had
over 12,000 nominations for restaurants
all over the
UK together with the best restaurant
team I've chosen the best and tonight my
two favorite restaurants will be going
head-to-head they may be good but do
they have what it takes to go right to
the
top for 6 months my team and I have
traveled all over
Britain tasting considering and arguing
over the great restaurants you nominated
I've put all these contenders through a
series of grueling pressure tests do you
understand me we are not going to be
late and I've been blown away by their
Drive determination and passion to reach
the final let's show the world what
prashad really is let's rock let's show
Ramsey let's go and now it's the final
showdown just two restaurants remain
incredible Indian cooking combining
passion and great skill Brad 's amazing
press Ard and my best Italian avantgard
Casmir from Bristol what a fight this is
going to be on the one hand I've got two
very talented young guys cooking Ultra
Modern Italian food like no other
restaurant anywhere in England today on
the other hand I've got this tiny Indian
restaurant headed up with mother and
daughter-in-law that quite honestly are
cooking some of the most delicious
vegetarian food I've ever tasted
anywhere in the world this for me is
going to be one of the most difficult
choices I've ever made
having made it this far both restaurants
think they have what it takes to win
this competition really want to win you
know there's no doubt about it we want
to win we're go in there to to to
hopefully uh be Crown Ramsey's best
restaurant we can do it you know what I
mean we can really seriously bloody do
it can't we yeah
absolutely kasemir's journey to this
point has been far from Easy their
avanguard take on Italian food is bold
and delicious really good presentation
uh unique but sometimes it's too
experimental and doesn't always always
hit the mark is the fish meant to be
cooked like this it's a bit of a strange
consistency it is in the semi-final
these ambitious Young Chefs showed me
they had the balls to strip back the
excessive FRS and become worthy
finalists well done you can smile you
can smile look at
you bref Pasad has been the surprise of
this competition and now this humble
restaurant has tasted success they're
hungry to win this is the tough very
tough competition I tell you work hard
and live to God we will fight so much
and we want to win we want to win it
will be a biggest day in my whole life
their small unpretentious restaurant
serves fantastic Gujarati Cuisine with
no airs or Graces that delicious one
mouthful of that I feel like I'm back in
Mumbai whatever I cook it's from my
heart I love
cooking I sent in a coachload of diners
but not everyone was happy to be in a
vegetarian
restaurant I'm a confirmed Carnival so
anything without meat isn't really clust
as a
meal but they all left converted amazing
presentation and then the taste itself I
think we'll try and come here again
mommy the Exquisite food and sheer
determination of Mel and Keli book them
their place in the final it's
Pasad everything has been building to
this moment one final grueling test
which will help me choose my best
restaurant my finalists are traveling to
petruse my new Central London restaurant
these luxurious surroundings will be the
battlefield for the biggest day of their
cooking careers it's here they'll fight
out for the title of my best restaurant
oh
wow stun Absolut St winning this will be
for everyone my parents my family my C
someone as
well haven't really sunk it until now
like this is like the final one this is
what we need to do the food's got be
absolutely perfect we ever done before
absolutely
crazy after all these years of putting
in hard work doing something what's
really different and people not
necessarily agreeing with it and
following us hopefully this is going to
prove a lot of people
wrong I believe my God help me so
definitely we work hard we coming to
work hard and hard and hard
and I can see what hardworking pay wow
factor good morning morning morning this
is it big day today you are in control
of your destiny Casmir versus
prad two unique restaurants going
head-to-head in the final good luck to
you both and may the best restaurant win
thank you very much thank you this is
the first time each restaurant has met
and now they're about to be pitched
head-to-head across my kitchen now
finally we met them we know who they are
and I think they are a strong candidate
as well so we need to work hard both
restaurants start prep and I'm expecting
nothing less than Perfection each team
must produce a stunning three course
menu that sums up what's best about
their restaurant encapsulates their love
of food and demonstrates their passion
for cooking if we get it right it'll
simply just be Bliss and people will
just enjoy it and say God damn that's is
a lovely
[Music]
dish Bobby and his brother mayor will be
running service for Pasad whilst Mom and
Dad team Paco and Susan will be running
front of house for the Casmir boys we
know the food is going to come
fantastically good so let's match the
food with the
service I've packed the dining room with
some of the brilliant restaurant teams
that have taken part in this competition
so both food and service will be under
extreme
scrutiny we're going to give our heart
on a plate in passion in love in dignity
every single thing counts
today and I've got one more surprise for
the restaurants my finalist will also be
cooking for one of Britain's best chefs
Angela harlet and my two secret
diners today there's no secret footage
you're actually be cooking live in front
of them sat on the chef's table and I'll
be tasting scrutinizing dissecting and
really getting to grips with what you
think is your best menu so far excited
very
y This Is It Make It Count do not send
anything that's less than 100% perfect
good luck thank you thanks Gordon we're
opening in 1 minute from now yeah good
luck off you go guys Good
Luck Good Luck yeah all the best we'll
do our best next will Casmir bottle it
on the biggest night of their lives that
was [__] let me tell you why you
can't stand there where you're head in a
pan and then run up to the hot plate and
start serving food and will Bobby blow
it for his wife and mother it's got to
go there they cannot go to a different
[__]
[Music]
table tonight I'm choosing my best
restaurant will it be Casmir from
Bristol or Pasad from
Bradford this will be the service of
their lives first up the
starters away now three stunning risoto
true to form John Ray and Peter are
pushing the boundaries with an
experimental
dish at their Bristol restaurant they're
known for their avangard take on Italian
cuisine still in their 20s these two
young chefs are fearless in their
approach to cooking they retain the
flavors and spirit of Italian food but
give it their unique
stamp we think in our own little world
almost and our own little bubble what
sometimes come cost as being young and
naive but I think it also helps create
what we are and that's something
different their startup for the final is
risoto with mushrooms and rosemary but
naturally it has a
Twist we're going to use new potatoes to
create little grains of rice that going
to give you that impression in the mouth
of you're eating rice but instead you
have that amazing flavor of potato this
dish is typical of Casmir it's clever
unusual and packed full of
flavor it would be a lot easier just to
get the rice I think but we will take it
to depths that not many chefs will have
the time or even patience to do first
the potatoes are laboriously cut into
individual shaped grains of rice next
Peter and JRE finally Cho garlic and
schlotz with a Precision of Surgeons
it's not all about speed sometimes it's
about perfection and getting it right
followed by butter mushrooms and bini
they're going to have a real depth
flavor to them a lot more than the fresh
mushroom itself it's about just playing
around with Texs and with flavors just
like a traditional risoto they start by
S sweating the schots off in olive oil
we don't want to bring any caramelized
flavors keep it very clean very pure
next they add the garlic and Pini so
that that start getting that background
flavor into the dish pour in the white
wine and reduce so now we're going to
put in the
potatoes exctly like we put in canori
rice and then go with our chicken stock
and what the chicken Stock's going to do
is just reduce bring out the starch from
the potato so you're going to start to
get the creaminess then they add
mushrooms chopped Rosemary grated
Parmesan just ity definitely it's just
fantastic butter for richness and to
give it a delicate onion note chop
chives we look at ourselves sometimes as
artists we don't just assume that we're
chefs what we do is just replicate
Master pieces of work again and again
and again finally this mouthwatering
masterpiece is finished with rosemarine
fused oil the flavors are
put I don't know where I like these pans
CU these pans man they're so small hey
they're so small I know they're [__] fu
the experimental nature of the boys
cooking means it requires extraordinary
attention to detail and this is really
slowing them down I just need some
bigger pants he's are very small why now
just say to me now that's what I said
you got to get organized guys the best
restaurant not the most disorganized no
stop to make matters worse they aren't
working together properly either as one
Cooks the first order the other should
be getting the next ready how long for
that first chef table please one minute
Chef thank you are you starting the six
behind it is anyone starting I'm just
saying is anyone starting okay good if I
boast about the teamwork it has to
deliver the teamw workk do you
understand there's no point in John Ray
watching you and you watching John R
let's go get involved together guys yes
sure it's really massive pressure but
hopefully we're just going to cook what
we always cook from the heart and
everything's going to be
perfect well it won't be if they don't
start working together customers are
waiting and cmir haven't served a single
dish when you said 8 minutes we're are
now on 12 minutes how long for the first
ratoo she have 2 minutes
per thank you let's go so is he not
going to serve it while you get the next
one ready come on guys Pete look at me
please can he look at me hey got no come
here both you a minute look so can he
not serve that while you get the next
one ready yes I do that come on guys
please finally the rotto leades the
kitchen he I just need a system now yes
Che so hey I know it's hard getting out
the traps I appreciate that but I need a
[__] system here otherwise we're
going to sink yes yeah sink sink sink
although the boys are sending out food
slowly their parents are doing their
best to be Charming so this is a new
potato risoto with wild mushrooms and
rosemary oil so playing with your mind
with uh different
textures the first restaurant cmir
defeated on their way to the final was a
fantastic Italian manula from London
what will head chef Santino think of
their stter they're pushing the
boundaries further they're taking what
Roto is and say let's take the rice out
and replace it with potato I mean who
the hell would do that I mean but it
really did work so it's very clever
thumbs up
definitely cir's food is going down well
but the boys are worryingly disorganized
that was [__] let me tell you why
you can't stand there where you head in
a pan and then run up to the hot plate
and start serving food and you can't
stand there my man and look around him
you've got to work together yes yes
popup Tander was amazing raw Lo the road
amazing but there seems to be no system
here today got to get a system come on I
know chef me time to find out what my
experts made of Casmir
sta rot how was it it delicious slightly
salty for me but overall flavor I
thought was delicious would that taste
better than a normal rato done with a
Bor rice what we said said what is the
point there's no point in having but
it's just different they're always
trying to do something different they're
always pushing it and Reinventing things
and that's quite fun that's did it work
yes or no I loved it did it work yes or
no yeah yes it
worked for their starter Pasad are
making chat a delicious take on a
traditional garati street
food prad's small 22 seat Indian
restaurant in Bradford has been at the
heart of the local community for 18
years over time they've transformed
humble vegetarian dishes from goodat in
Northwest India into something truly
magical when I'm making any food I'm so
happy I put my positive thinking and my
love so I'm making not for the business
I'm making like my family chats a
popular Street dish but isn't easy to
prepare this recipe has layer upon layer
of wonderful
flavors look simple and sound simple but
lot of going on three sauces boiling
potatoes boiling chickpeas frying
pastries making chili sauce making
noodles we making our own samosas it's
complicated first manow prepares a rich
Tamarind sauce by boiling Tamarind dates
and jaggery and unrefined cane sugar
sour is a tamarine and sweet we going to
put some
so right balance sweet and sour next CI
slices Samosa pastry leaves into squares
and deep fries fried brown color then
crispy for the noodles Manel Blends gram
flour with sunflower oil it's like soft
smooth if it's not smooth then is noodle
be
funky meanwhile Cal's on to the next
sauce blending garlic chili powder salt
and lemon juice want to try yeah she
like very hot things I like extra hot
then the samosas first they fry peas and
add turmeric coriander and garam masala
a special blend of
spices garam masala is my own garam
masala I roast it and then I grind it
myself that's why the everything so
tasty finally potatoes are boiled diced
and turned into the mix the last process
is a delicate one filling the Samosa
pastry it's lot to do if something goes
wrong it's difficult Samosa is a you
know is a very tricky very tricky the
balance of flavors and textures in this
dish Are Pitch Perfect sweet sour spicy
crunchy and soft the way that Pasad
bring vegetarian food to life is a
revelation I am 100% you will
win pad 5 CS away table one yes thank
you okay I want to hear you just
disintegrated M I want to hear you
[Music]
mommy five have gone I need six now
please thank you yeah in contrast to the
Casmir boys minel and Ki are shown
fantastic teamwork from the word go mom
yes you're all right yes fine how are
you
fine you doing those other two please uh
Mel yeah good okay good thank you milel
and Ki are really hitting their stride
their organization is spot on but they
need to watch their
presentation all this step off there
yeah all now every time yeah I can't
wipe your plates I cannot wipe your
plates yeah okay go please that's Table
Three okay Bobby is integral to the
success of Pasad his service throughout
the competition has been charismatic
professional and knowledgeable hi there
you enjoying combination of flavors
thank you thank you yeah we try to it's
a traditional Street dish so basically
the hot with the cold the sweet with the
spicy uh just to kind of ignite all your
flavors all the way through the meal
he's also playing his part in the
kitchen encouraging minel and giving a
customer feedback mnow yes table number
three compliments to the chef the
starters are amazing thank you keep
coming thank you but just when it's all
going so right dishes get sent to the
wrong
table and Bobby's two starters
short the seven and eight starters have
been plated to a ready table for
starters which is table number five can
I take two of these and complete that St
a mistake like this can throw a kitchen
into chaos if they're not clear they
come back down with a tray okay and they
tell me and I Rectify it again okay they
cannot go to a different [__] table
so when I send two chat away on seven
and two away on table 8 it's got to go
there Manel doesn't miss the beat she
just deals with the problem smoothly and
efficiently I cannot have this mistake
starting with the main course okay
let's go I need two
more got a bit of a telling off not good
uh but we've rectified that how long for
the chat 5 minutes let's
go hey we got two table one please let's
go nice and steady let's go wa now two
sh let's go
lot in the first round of the
competition Pasad came up against
another exceptional Indian the brilliant
from London what will front of house
manager dipner think of their chat I
really like it the combination of the
sweet and the kind of Tangy flavor comes
through really nicely now to hear what
my experts made of Pasad stter I quite
like The Adventurous task of trying to
put the hot
Samosa inside the garnish the joy of
prashad is that they are very
comfortable within their own boundaries
and you know we've eaten some fantastic
food up in
Bradford okay go please good clear down
well done well done well done well done
Stars finished I need to taste both
dishes what
chat nice got that heat that nice sweet
tamaron flavor I like the hot Samosa
running through but it's got that
balance between the sweet Savory and the
heat there as well very good rotto of
new potatoes only these guys would turn
potatoes into granules of
rice it's very rich for the seps you can
only eat two or three mouthfuls of it so
it's not not like a proper risotto
however very clever if there's one
criticism on that it's just a touch too
salty two very interesting starters um
right now which one you prefer out of
those
two I'd have to say
Pasad next will Casmir get out of first
gear send some food will you let's go
unbelievable [__] you two do my
[__] eding I swear to God and will
prad Buckle under the
[Music]
pressure
my final is Casmir the cry Alchemist
from Bristol and Pasad the masters of
vegetarian Indian Cuisine from Bradford
are battling out for the title of my
best restaurant I want both these
amazing restaurants to do their talent
Justice tonight so I'm expecting
perfection in their main courses it's
getting very tough now it's coming the
main course and the main course is a
tough okay cir threee stunning t away
Chef's Table yes yes chef pad three
stunning Bindy Chef table okay looking
fantastic yeah really good hey k a
little bit slow they need to improve
their coordination skills rather than
sort of trying to cook silently as one
table's going they have one working so
there's not that static in between John
Ray and Peter never make life easy for
themselves at their restaurant in
Bristol they're always pushing the
boundaries with their food trying to
create new and exciting flavor and
texture combination
sometimes we play too extreme but I
think that's just because it's the way
we are we will always take it that step
further we'll never hold back we'll
always put it up there and give it our
best shot for their main cause they've
stayed true to their inventive Spirit
pairing meat with fish when Peter first
presented this to me and I tried it I
was just blown away I just thought it
worked fantastically they're cooking
roast turbet with chicken wings and
roast
salfy Peter starts by fting the fish and
it isn't long before he pulls out one of
his potions now we're going to use
something called protein glue protein
glue or trans glutamin eyes literally
bonds fillets together by just
sprinkling it over the
top then we just match up the fillets
from the top to the bottom we create
that kind of big thick piece of fish
then the salfi a vegetable from the root
of the purple salfi flour it's very
earthy but it's got sweetness as well
almost like a a kind of sweetness of
oyster true to Casmir form all the
ingredients in this dish are cooked Sid
in a water bath so we place that inside
a vacuum Pat bag the fish takes 15
minutes the chicken wings take 12 hours
anything good takes time I think as long
as we can see a great end result then
it's worth all the time in the world
next to Herb Jew a blend of chive Shel
and parsley is pureed finely cved and
then placed in this machine that creates
a vacuum removing all the air bubbles we
use this all the time constantly so
there's no more waiting 4 days for
things to rest in the fridge so the airc
comes right so you see now it's pure
I've criticized Casmir for overusing the
water bath because not all ingredients
suit it so have they learned their
lesson the whole secret is just finish
it in a pan and just let the skin just
crisp and create that caramelized golden
flavor and it unbelievable absolutely
unbelievable it's great news because
customers are comfortable with pan
frying but it's just one more stage in
an already complicated process the most
key thing is the timing of everything
now if the timing's not there then we'll
pretty much be
screwed
this is beautiful refined cooking
Simplicity on the plate achieved with
technical precision and attention to
detail we're under a massive amount of
pressure today you know Gordon wants
110% and he pushes you all the way not
only does he want speed uh some
communication but he wants a dish that's
going to out perfect you obviously you
see tonight we got like 31 Chef table we
got F and the rest of the diner so
absolutely mad experience cir's main
course is a complicated dish and it will
demand the kind of teamwork work they
haven't shown yet can't get no color get
no heat the boys are still infuriatingly
slow getting food out I need to see some
form of [__] teamwork going on and
there's one thing I've got with you guys
is a stop start stop start you got to
get 21st century flow it's nice to push
the boat out we got to get into a flow
yes finally they seem to be hitting
their stride should just like over the
sou yeah one there one there and the
food looks amazing yeah good go please
table one thank you let's go guys but
how has the unusual combination of
chicken and fish gone down with my
diners turbo Works excellently with me I
think this absolutely sound choice that
they made the turbo was perfect the
chicken weaves were really good and the
Sai brought it all together the
creaminess in the middle again it's what
I expect from Kazmir they're very clever
they know what they're doing and it was
executed really good let's go that's
ready that tur looks fantastic guys yeah
keep it going yes yes chef for
sh whilst the boys's daring dish has
really impressed upstairs their parents
su su are clearly feeling the
strain on the pillow for the other lady
yeah okay pet sh right stop going on pet
with one course still to go will they be
able to hold it together I'm feeling a
little bit under pressure a little bit
this is Gordon Ramsey best restaurant
you want to do your best time to find
out my experts on the chef table thought
of kasemir's main course I think
elements on that plate were fantastic
from Casmir I love the roasted S I love
the way they used turel on the plate I
thought that was delicious it a
fantastic combination the Jew brought
the whole thing together seasoned the
whole plate perfect yeah I thought it
was a good effort you know they the
salie puree was delicious the roasted
Sal we we show up an experience when
they're hard you know they did it
perfectly and they're being really
really inventive they're coming up with
new dishes specifically for this
competition I yeah I admire that yeah
the
business in contrast to Casmir prad have
chosen to cook a simpler main course
it's not hard because every day we
making this we so happy God Alik he said
very good very good so we happy we happy
we got a confidence now they're putting
their faith in a dish that's loved by
the devoted band of Bradford regulars
what we chosen the meal is a
traditionally Gujarati meal okra is very
popular my customer love the okra Indo
prad is a fting selling this the key to
pad's success is the way they transform
traditional family recipes with their
unique balance of tastes textures and
spices in India every 2 days we eat in
Okra and the Dal and the rice for the
main course they're cooking okra Curry
Ser with a garati Dal soup rice and
Rita Min now starts by chopping an onion
and frying it with fener Greek seeds and
chopped garlic then Ki adds turmeric red
chili powder ground coriander and
tomatoes next the okra sometimes called
ladies fingers it's a type of green bean
it's sticky inside so if you dry them
there before it's better if you make
fresh then it stick with each other Ki
fries it and adds it to the
curry next the lentil soup or Dal lentil
is th time because we need to boil it's
not ready at least 15
minutes
when the lentils are ready Manel
liquidize them and then adds liquidized
Tomatoes then the Pasad magic turmeric
red chili powder juger and finally
coriander this is a very balanced meal
because okra it's not too spicy curry
that lentil soup it's very creamy and
Rich and little bit of sweet and Tangi
so flavor is balanced very well finally
minel fries dried chilies and adds cumin
and then returns to the dll
I'm just checking where it is yeah he's
done in Indian Cuisine is a not much
going on in the presentation so now I
have to try bit
harder as Garden says we need finess
when we serving the complex interplay of
taste Works brilliantly in this dish
creamy crunchy cold spicy pada always
trying to elevate humble vegetables to O
cuisine
how long for the five please 10 minut 10
minutes thank you what's really
impressing me today is how pad are
trying to keep the soul of their homely
garati dishes but giving them a facelift
for my
[Music]
restaurant but as service ramps up even
pad's calm facade is beginning to crack
food has been spilled and they're
starting to get in each other's way
excuse me
please
meile you got spare yeah I got
plenty put on it good
luck yeah away
now but Bobby's back on form and holding
it together in the dining room we're in
the flow now the food's coming up it's
it's good and it's been received well
have Pasad done enough to convince my
diners their main cause is worthy of the
final much better
presentation much better it's
contemporary modern which I like I've
never thought I I liked OA this Oka is
is delicious isn't it beautiful but will
it be enough to impress my demanding
experts pads Bindy how was that okra the
tastes were really intense very powerful
and really expertly done and done with
ease you can tell the person that cooked
that they just do it with ease it comes
you know it's very passionate and it
just it's really skillful very impressed
very hard to get okra tasting delicious
but it was good the OPA was great I just
think they could have lifted everything
slightly one level
[Music]
up okay cing now main CA is all gone
good job great job yes clear down get
ready for desserts yes after judging the
starters I've put Pasad ahead on the
night has casimir's main pulled it back
okay main courses
Casmir turbet cooked
water
bath P
right delicious there's elements of
maturity across this plate because
they're listening they're using the
techniques they're akin to with this
slow cooking water bath but they're
bringing in you know the roasting of the
tub at the end very clever but the
chicken the tubet work there's Harmony
there really good
PR
wow
that's delicious just you want more
aqua's delicious got a little crunch it
really is vibrant and a nice blend of
spices really nice what they have done
across this main course is they've
refined it they've really brought guati
toon night's Bridge both teams have
really taken on board my constructive
prison and today delivered two fantastic
main courses which one would I
prefer right now both of them
the dessert will be the decider both
teams have to keep their nerve and cook
the dish of their lives right guys last
course M Ki last course keep it going
yes okay end on a high yes from their
small Deli attached to the restaurant in
Bradford prashad serve a huge range of
deliciously sweet Indian desserts which
Ki and Manel are attempting to modernize
for their final dish they hope will win
them this competition we making homemade
Indian sweets this sweets is a delicate
same time is a rich also Garden will
definitely like it he like my food so
I'm sure he like this one also all three
of their traditional Indian desserts use
a combination of ghee flour and sugar
either refined white or the Indian
favorite jaggery and unrefined sugar
that is extremely sweet but extremely
popular in Indian
desserts sesame seed and Zary get
together very well one's rolled with
sesame seeds another is flattened spiced
with cardamon then finished with
pistachios and
almonds and the third and final Suite is
a simple blend of sesame seeds and
jaggery that is cut into
squares and the finished dish will be
washed down with sweet and ginger
tea in India people how they dring the
tea half milk half water boiling up put
some ginger and sugar and keep boiling
until it's really good
taste I think P been clever to create a
simple dish that is easy to plate and
and requires very little cooking during
service it's a nice way of finishing a
classic main course what I like about it
it's quite modern and they've sort of
taken a leaf out of Casmir book there
and thought well they're doing that with
Italian food I can do that with
vegetarian Indian food clever they look
fantastic but before I make my own mind
up I want to see what my experts and
diners think of these modernized Indian
sweets I was quite excited the way they
made them look almost like a sort of um
little miniature pett
very very sweet they look pretty they
look pretty uh but they were just ey
wateringly sweet sometimes you get a
sugar rush this kind of gave me a sugar
bash on the head you know yeah just too
much very different but then they're
quite traditional within themselves so I
thought that was a nice mixture of old
and new and trying to mix it up a bit I
like the one at the end which was the
slightly harder one um to me mainly cuz
it was less sweet you know it had a
great structure to it you know had a
lovely sort of buttery nutty flavor to
it I don't think they'll ever get away
from those over sweetness star but I
have to applaud them for their
modernization of a dessert I thought it
was great yeah I think they did a great
thing to actually flavors on this
probably remind me of one Indian very
spicy very um fragrant when I actually
bit into the um there was one Sesame L
which we call it that was really nice I
really like that I don't like ginger tea
at all but I like that ginger tea wasn't
too gingery if I if I must say so Casmir
again John R Peter end on a high please
yes last course yeah come on make it
well yes for Casmir to beat this they'll
have to really pull something out the
bag but the panac cotas they prepared
earlier were way too thick so now
they've set they're much too solid just
m back down the panac cotas at the
moment so just getting the gelatine
level right putting more milk into it
put some penuts back in some sugar and
uh hopefully restore feet this is a
brave move late in the day but
everything these boys do is risky
especially the rest of the dessert that
they've been perfecting in their Bristol
HQ
we always tried to go out with a big
bang or a big wow it's going to be an
award-winning dish and it's going to win
this goam competition the first part is
a lemon sbet but the boys are not using
just any
lemons mouthy lemons amazing we use them
all the time in the kitchen cuz they're
bloody brilliant um they're not as harsh
as normal lemons um and they got a
fantastic Aroma for us the desserts are
such an important part but the lemons
will not just be used in the SB the
Amalfi Coast is in southern Italy and
that is where the boys want to take the
diners we want to almost recreate that
mouthy C smell that's the plan that's a
little magic plan that we've got in our
head the boys are making a lemon tea
which they pour over the kitchen
Alchemist
favorite the tea is going to be infused
with zest lemon juice that's going to be
poured on the bottom what's going to be
hot we're going to pour liquid nitrogen
that's going to flood the ARA around the
table bloody brilliant and it works
really
well this end of the night spectacular
could steal the show If Only They get it
out on time just send some food will you
let's go unbelievable everything hangs
on the panacotta if it collapses so all
their dreams are becoming my best
restaurant panot turned out absolutely
perfect so I'm really happy with it
brilliant
texture that consistency looks lovely
thank you
Chef the panacotta is perfect and now's
the moment when it should all come
together yeah just let it so you got a
little bit more
okay my air
conditioning cir's liquid nitrogen
Wizardry has wowed my experts and the
diners but is this just another Casmir
gimmick oh that's lovely oh that is very
clever the proof of the pudding is as
ever in the
eating very good very very good
delicious this is wonderful this is
really really special panacotta an how
was that I mean for me it was delicious
I mean me to test you just move it and
it's got that wobbliness to it the
structure I thought the lemon with the
pine nut was absolutely brilliant and I
mean I'm might you I hate the gimmicky
normally but I thought it served its
purpose I love the way they tried to get
that extra element in there so it's all
the senses it's smell it tast yes it did
work definitely it did more than work it
it enhanced it it wasn't just a gimmick
when you're very inventive like like
those chefs are sometimes it's just all
invention and no practicality there's no
purpose to it that had purpose and it
added to it and what a finale I mean it
just look amazing great the it was great
the for the restaurant it worked for the
[Music]
dish for kame and Pasad it has taken a
shedload of Drive determination and
skill to get to the final all our
customer are happy they eaten the food
they plate are empty that's why we are
reliefed now when we Rel we're going to
win definitely we are I don't know if we
want it's too close to call again it's
too close these guys are faster than us
tonight there's no doubt about it we run
around like Pricks literally run around
like Pricks in know but we we did that
to show we can cook in the dining room
thoughts now turned to which restaurant
the diners
preferred My Vault definitely K here I
would say overall that I preferred
pasart I really enjoy Pasad and my team
on the chef's table have offered their
expert analysis the start of main course
dessert was it imbalance did it had
finesse did it work across the three
courses both brigades took risks in
different way by the time they came to
the end of their main course they were
in their Rhythm theyve got those nerves
on top of the fact this is a massive
competition you sudden clear who's
[__] winning in your C that's for
sure I like the way he's read the
balance in there I've listened to
everyone else's opinions now I have to
decide who should be my best restaurant
but before I choose I'm going to taste
the crucial dessert course desserts
should always end on a high pad they've
done a little selection of desserts s me
see very very sweet very heavy and then
you sort of wash that down with a ginger
chai yes nice tees lovely no one really
knows Indian desserts that well so to
cut them up into almost like little
sweet Petty fors they are delicious
quite nice with that sweet and savory
quite light and again you've got that
that Vibrance nice here we go the mfy
hills come to night's
Bridge all that fragrant zest that's
like lemon pulp in there over the dry
ice and really nice rich and malfy
lemons
beautiful wow it's almost like you're
taking a steam bar of fragrant lemon now
the
texture that's lovely you've got that
Cary pine nuts infused across the
panacotta really nice but the whole
thing's fresh and fragrant two very
interesting desserts across the board
and uh love pad's little finesse with
their dessert brilliant Casmir
these guys are smart which one for me
would I eat
again next I'll be making one of the
hardest decisions I've ever had to make
the winner and a mighty
congratulations only one can be crowned
my best restaurant goes
[Music]
to
two outstanding restaurants both of whom
have proved they can deliver at the
highest
level I'm about to reveal which one is
worthy of the title of my best
[Music]
restaurant okay first of all well done
what what a night and my god did the
customers love it tense
day difficult day both restaurants have
been under immense
pressure
kameir tonight's performance you must
have balls the size of melons to
announce a risotto and not put rice
anywhere near the dish you made it out
of potatoes customers loved it then the
combination of the the turbet and the
chicken wing tough to get that meat and
fish working at the same
time it worked and then the finale not
just the wow factor with the texture of
the panacotta but that kind of Magic on
top of
that prad you left the boy standing
today with the way that you organize
yourselves okra one of the most unwanted
vegetables anywhere in the country serve
with a
doll yeah they loved it I know
Mich star Indian restaurants in this
city that can't put food on a plate like
that well done desserts they're never
ever going to be every's cup of tea
because it's like a sweet Petty fall but
I love the attitude to refine
it Well
Done Castle may you managed to excite in
a way that very few restaurants do but
you're only going to be highly
successful when your customers are with
you and sometimes you step too far and
you forget the
[Music]
customers
pushard caly your heart is bigger than
any woman's I ever
known
you're too
generous put more in the till yeah and
stop giving it
away
okay that's been my experience from
start to finish it's been a tempestuous
Journey based on everything I've
experienced
tasted
witnessed the winner and a mighty
congratulations goes
to
Casmir well done bab well done
Ki
pad my darling that is for you
congratulations well done well done my
darling thank you well done Bobby well
done
Casmir John Ray Pete congratulations
well well deserved well done well done
well done well done well done well done
well done come here well
done good job good job well done well
done I'm just amazed I'm absolutely
amazed it's just unbelievable it's like
a dream come true
so I'm just so GL
man
oh my voice we just put everything we
could into it absolutely everything I
mean I've never
give so much energy and passion of
dishes in all my life
literally I know you're disappointed M I
know but we haven't lost became second
remember you're two in 12,000 month two
yeah we are disappointed but Prasad need
to grow we want to learn more and we we
going to be successful one day I'm
totally gutted for Pasad you know you've
got two self-taught ladies that cooked
here tonight as if they were cooking for
their lives their food's
amazing but Pasad was up against two
real thorough breads that are going to
leave a a lasting impression there were
elements of that dinner tonight that was
of a three star standard a three Mission
star standard where chefs spent 253
years to perfect this is you because you
back to us what youve
uh me and Pete to
do and the direction you uh V you kind
of the direction and the vision you had
on kind of what me and Pete wanted to do
with food and allow us to do
[Music]
it give me a second my [__]
together Ser you mean so so much
and yeah I trust you boys I trust you I
could see the
talent tonight for Paco and Susan was
payback night because their sons proved
why their mom and dad have backed them
all the way and tonight they sha I mean
they really sha Cheers
Cheers